You're trying to do well in the class
and you get a bad grade.
Okay,
so you're in this little frame.
You want to get a good grade that isn't
happening.
He got a bad grade.
Okay,
what is it that's manifesting itself as
the bad grade?
While you could say,
well,
it's a c minus on a piece of paper.
It's like,
well,
that's really.
Know that that's the objective
manifestation.
You got a piece of paper with a c minus
the value free proposition is that
you've been delivered a piece of paper
with a curve on it.
A little negative side.
Well you say,
well,
that's what that is.
Well,
you know it's as dopey is thinking,
well,
here you got your failing grade.
You go into the lab and you weigh it on
a scale.
Then you burn it and see what it was
made of.
It's like,
well,
why did I get so upset about that?
It's just paper.
It's like,
no,
that's not just paper.
It's an entity that exists in a web of
connections.
The fact that it signified by papers
almost completely irrelevant.
What is it?
The answer is you don't know,
and that's why when you pick it up,
you get this paralyzed,
sinking feeling because your limbic
system is a lot smarter than your
perceptual systems and your perceptual
systems say,
well,
that's a piece of paper and your limbic
system says,
Nah,
for sure dragon.
Right?
Right.
And so then you're sweating and then
maybe you put it away and you go play
video games because you know better the
hypothetical dragon,
then the real dragon.
And so instead you pull out the piece of
paper maybe and you think,
okay,
why did I get this c minus?
Well that's a hell of a question,
isn't it?
It's like maybe you're stupid.
Well,
that could be,
or at least stupid compared to who you
think you are.
Like that's,
that's the real horror that's lurking
there,
right?
It's like,
oh,
I thought I was kind of smart.
That's a,
that's a proposition of the highest
order.
I thought I was kind of smart.
So like,
yeah,
well what about this c minus?
It's like,
well that God damn professor,
right?
That's the first thing.
I've been attacked by a predator.
That's the first response,
right?
So it's,
it's a nonsensical message.
It's just delivered by someone evil in
predatory.
Well that's,
you know,
possible.
But I wouldn't go there.
I wouldn't go there first necessarily.
So.
But then.
Well then say you don't go there.
Okay.
Well,
so what is this exactly?
Do you not know what you thought you
knew?
What are you not who you think you are?
Do you don't work hard enough?
Are Your values not organized properly?
Do you misuse your time?
Are you in the wrong field?
Is the way you're construing Your Life
Completely Inappropriate?
Are you acting out what your parents
wanted you to do and you're pissed off
about it?
So you're only running at 40 percent to
spite them despite the fact that they're
paying $25,000
a year for your education because that's
a fun game.
Yeah,
I'll go do what you want me to do,
but I'll fail at,
but not completely because then that
would cost you very much.
I'll just fail a little bit so that you
have to spend all that money forcing me
to what I don't want to do,
but you'll never get to escape from it,
and then every time we interact,
I'll stab you in various ways that you
don't quite understand,
just to show you how irritated I am that
I happened to be acting out the destiny
that you've put forward for me.
So maybe that's part of the Dragon,
right?
And then that pulls in the whole parent
thing and these are bottomless pits.
Often when you,
when you're in the world and something
objects to you,
something that matters,
objects to you than the entire on
realized world is in that thing that
objects.
It's all tangled up inside.
If that's why it's the great dragon of
chaos.
It's everything that's outside of your
conceptual structure and what is that?
It's everything that lurks outside of
your,
of your walled city,
and it's manifested itself like the
snake in the garden and the easiest
thing to do is say,
I'm not having anything to do with that,
but the problem with that is,
well,
you get your c minus and you don't do
anything about it.
Maybe you're a little bitter and more
resentful and your study habits get a
little worse.
So the next time you get like a d plus,
and then you collect a bunch of f's and
then you stopped going to school.
Then you stop showering,
right?
Then you end up jumping off the bridge.
And so that's,
uh,
that's,
that's how the dragon eats you when you
don't pay attention to it.
And so it's no bloody wonder that people
avoid,
you know,
it's really no wonder that they avoid
because error messages contain within
them the implicit world.
Now the upside of that is while they
contain within them the implicit world
and the world isn't all negative and so
maybe you get your c minus and that's
actually the best gift you ever got
because somebody finally took you and
went whack,
you know,
clue in.
And so you take that apart and you
think,
oh,
I don't know how to write.
I don't know how to think.
I've never read anything in my life.
My study habits are abysmal.
You know,
like maybe I'm working at two percent
efficiency,
which,
which is probably,
I would suspect that,
you know,
some of you aren't doing that,
but I bet you that I bet there's 30,
30 to 50 percent of the people in the
room are working at two percent
efficiency.
It's like you got it.
That.
So to find that out is so optimistic.
I mean if you're barely hanging in
there,
but you're only working at two percent,
you might imagine what you could have as
a life if you work at,
at like 50 percent.
So,
so the,
the c minus can be the best gift you
ever had and that's the gold that the
dragon hordes,
right?
That's exactly what that means.
And so well,
so you're moving from point a to point
b.
In your little circumscribed world,
you've made everything invisible and as
long as that works,
then your theory is good enough.
It's accurate enough,
it's true enough,
you're in your little paradise.
But if something comes up and objects,
well that's where your character is
tested.
Fundamentally,
that's the character test.
It's like what do you do with messages
of error?
And that's a tricky issue.
Okay,
so here's the solution to that.
Here's what not to do.
I am a bad person.
I go to see my.
I'm a bad person.
I might as well just go jump off the
bridge.
It's like,
no,
that's not good.
Because what means is that every time,
every time you try to learn something,
you're going to make a mistake because
what do you know?
So you're going to make mistakes.
And if the rule is every time you make a
mistake,
you're going to go jump off the bridge,
then that's not a useful problem solving
strategy.
And so when you make a mistake,
you don't get to beat yourself to death
with a club,
it's a bad strategy,
and you'll have your internal tyrant in
there who's perfectly happy about doing
that.
That's the overactive super ego that
Freud talked about.
Maybe it came to you via a parent who
was too authoritarian or a grandparent
or a,
or maybe it's just you because you're
disagreeable in neurotic.
And so you'll take your hyper
conscientious.
You'll take yourself apart.
Well,
starting the so you've got a problem.
Something has objected to you.
Then the question is,
well,
what does that mean?
Well,
maybe you're not looking at the world,
right?
Maybe your goals are wrong.
Maybe you're not acting properly.
So okay,
so the question that arises when an
obstacle emerges is which part of this
structure needs attention?
And the first answer can't be all of it,
which is why when you're arguing with
someone in an intimate relationship and
you're angry at them and you want to
win,
which is a big mistake,
you want to,
when you say,
well you're,
this is what you're like,
here's another 10 examples of how you've
done that in the past and I can
enumerate more of them if you'd like.
And so it doesn't,
that's actually what you like and I've
tried fixing you and didn't work.
And so it looks like you're going to be
like that up into the future.
And you're basically saying to them,
well,
you're a bad person.
And the only thing they can do is either
collapse or punch you and punching you
is actually better than collapsing.
Like you don't.
You know what I mean?
It's such a counterproductive way of
arguing.
You don't leave the person handing out.
And so maybe while they're civilized so
it doesn't get physical,
well maybe that's good and maybe it
isn't.
But then they end up either really not
happy with you in a way that they will
manifest the first possible opportunity
they get or they have to go off in the
corner and cringe.
It's like,
great,
you won.
It's like now your partners either hates
you or is cringing.
It's great.
That's a real good victory man.
Rack up about 100 victories like that.
And you'll be in divorce court and
spending $250,000
while being miserable about it.
Yeah.
So anyway,
so something objects to you and you
think,
okay,
well I need to,
I need to take myself apart.
Right?
Because there's a piece that's broken
somewhere and then you might think,
well let's,
let's assume it's a little piece to
begin with.
That's the right mechanism.
It's like,
okay,
you got a c minus that doesn't prove
that you're stupid and now it implies
that you might be stupid,
but it doesn't.
Right.
Really it does.
And that's why you don't want to look at
it.
Maybe it implies that you're lazier,
implies that you're ignorant or like it
implies all sorts of terrible.
Might imply that you're a bad person
even,
but you don't want to leap to that and
that's sort of the proclamation of
innocence before guilt.
Assume that you're the least amount of
reprehensible and ignorant possible.
And so then you look at the micro
routines.
So okay,
well I got a c minus in this course.
Maybe I should study for that course,
15 minutes more a day for the next three
months.
And then you ask yourself,
do you think you could do that?
No,
I'm too useless.
Okay,
how about 15 minutes every second day
you think you could do that?
You put it in your schedule like 15
minutes every second day in the morning
and that's why you think,
well,
what's wrong with me?
Well,
I'm not very good at managing my study
schedule.
That's not quite down here at the
behavioral level,
but it's pretty close because what?
You can take an action,
you can open up your schedule and you
can say,
Oh mark,
15 minutes away aside.
Then you can practice doing that.
It's pretty low level in the hierarchy
means while you're still not a horrible
person,
you just got to polish up your work
ethic.